REPORT" IS UP NEXT.
HEY, BRET.
>> Bret: HEY, GREG, HAPPY
EARTH DAY.
HOUSE DEMOCRATS ARE TEARING DOWN
ANOTHER GAUNTLET IN A BIGGER
BATTLE OVER THE MUELLER REPORT,
THERE WOULD BE A POINT MAN FOR
IMPEACHMENT, JERRY NADLER HAS
SUBPOENAED A WHITE HOUSE INSIDER
IN A FUTURE PLAYER IN THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL NARRATIVE,
FORMER WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL DON
MCGANN IS THE SUBJECT OF THAT
SUBPOENA.
THE WEIGHTING RESPONSE FROM THE
TRUMP TEAM, JOHN ROBERTS STARTS
US OFF TONIGHT WITHOUT BREAKING
NEWS.
GOOD EVENING?
>> GOOD EVENING, WAITING A
RESPONSE, UNKNOWN IF THE
WHITE HOUSE WILL GET EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE, ALSO UNCLEAR AT THIS
POINT HOW MUCH MORE CONGRESS CAN
LEARN AGAIN THAT IS NOT ALREADY
KNOWN.
REMEMBER THAT THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER
INTERVIEWED HIM, AND DID NOT
FIND CRIMINAL OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
BUT THIS IS THE LATEST IN A
BLIZZARD OF SUBPOENAS EXPECTED
TO COME DOWN OFF OF
CAPITOL HILL, BUT WHILE IT IS
SHORT OF IMPEACHMENT, NO DOUBT
WILL TIE THE WHITE HOUSE IN
KNOTS.
>> AT THE ANNUAL EASTER EGG
ROLL, PRESIDENT TRUMP WEIGHED IN
ON TALK OF IMPEACHMENT, TAKING A
WHAT?
ME, WORRY?
APPROACH.
>> ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT?
>> THE PRESIDENT'S CONFIDENCE
WOULD SHOW THE SINKING OF THE
DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP, AND HOUSE
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI WRITING
WHILE OUR VIEW RAINS FROM
PERCEIVING THE INVESTIGATION OF
THE MUELLER REPORT TO
IMPEACHMENT, WE ALL FIRMLY AGREE
THAT WE SHOULD PROCEED DOWN A
PATH OF FINDING THE TRUTH.
IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO KNOW
THAT THE FACTS REGARDING HOLDING
THE PRESIDENT ACCOUNTABLE CAN BE
GAINED OUTSIDE OF IMPEACHMENT
HEARINGS, THE ONE THAT WOULD
TAKE UP IMPEACHMENT APPEARED TO
HESITATE WHEN ASKED.
>> Bret: DO YOU THINK THAT
THIS IS IMPEACHABLE?
>> YEAH, I DO.
IF PROVEN, IF PROVEN, WHICH HAS
NOT BEEN PROVEN YET, SOME OF
THIS COULD BE IMPEACHABLE, YES.
>> WHILE SOME 2020 DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES HAVE STAYED AWAY FROM
ANY TALK OF IMPEACHMENT,
ELIZABETH WARREN SEEKING A BOOST
TO THE LEGGING CAMPAIGN SAYS
THAT SHE IS ALL IN.
>> I JUST CALLED ON THE HOUSE TO
INITIATE IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP MOCKS SUCH
TALK FIRING BACK ONLY HIGH
CRIMES AND MISDEMEANORS CAN LEAD
TO IMPEACHMENT.
THERE WERE NO CRIMES BUT I MEAN,
NO COLLUSION, NO OBSTRUCTION, SO
YOU CANNOT IMPEACH.
IT WAS THE DEMOCRATS THAT
COMMITTED THE CRIMES, NOT YOUR
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT WAS ALSO ON
OFFENSE ON THE FINANCIAL FRONT,
SUING CHAIRMAN ELIJAH CUMMINGS
FOR TRYING TO SUBPOENA FINANCIAL
RECORDS FROM THE ACCOUNTING
FIRM.
IN THE LAWSUIT TRUMP ATTORNEYS
ATTACKING THE SUBPOENA WRITING
"IT'S GOAL IS TO EXPOSE
PLAINTIFF'S PRIVATE
INFORMATIONAL FOR THE SAKE OF
EXPOSURE THAT IT WILL TURN UP
SOMETHING THAT DEMOCRATS CAN USE
AS A POLITICAL TOOL AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT NOW AND IN THE 2020
ELECTION."
SOURCES SAY THAT THE SUBPOENA
GOES WELL BEYOND REQUEST FOR THE
PRESIDENT'S FINANCIAL RECORDS,
ALSO SEEKING THOSE AND ALL OF
HIS CHILDREN INCLUDING BARRON
AND TIFFANY TRUMP, MICHAEL
COHEN, A FELON WHO HAS PLEADED
GUILTY TO CONGRESS SAYS THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAD MISREPRESENTED HIS
NET WORTH WHEN HE WAS A PRIVATE
CITIZEN.
ELIJAH CUMMINGS APPEARED
UNFAZED.
IN A STATEMENT THIS AFTERNOON
SAYING THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS A
LONG HISTORY OF TRYING TO USE
BASELESS LAWSUITS TO ATTACK HIS
ADVERSARIES.
BUT THERE WAS SIMPLY NO VALID
LEGAL BASIS TO INTERFERE WITH
THE DULY AUTHORIZED SUBPOENA
FROM CONGRESS.
THE ATTORNEYS INSISTED THAT HE
HAS LONG BEEN UNDER THIS
GUARANTY OF THE FEDERAL AGENCY,
THAT IT IS THE IRS PURVIEW NOT
CONGRESS IS TO LOOK INTO
PEOPLE'S FINANCIAL RECORDS, THEY
ALSO POINT OUT THAT THE IRS HAS
LOOKED AT PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR
YEARS UPON YEARS AND HAS FOUND
NO REASON TO BRING ANY KIND OF
ACTION CIVIL OR CRIMINAL AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT.
>> Bret: CHAIRMAN NADLER
DROPPED THE SUBPOENA AS HOUSE
DEMOCRATS ARE MEETING ON THIS
CONFERENCE CALL ABOUT NEXT STEPS
AFTER THE MUELLER REPORT.
THE WHITE HOUSE DID NOT HOLD
BACK, DID NOT ISSUE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE FOR ANY OF THOSE
MUELLER REPORT OR THE TESTIMONY
BEFORE, IS THERE A THOUGHT THAT
THEY MAY STEP UP AGAIN AND DO
THAT?
>> WE DO NOT KNOW IF THEY ARE
GOING TO EXERT EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE, TESTIFYING BEFORE
CONGRESS, BUT THE ENTIRE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION THAT CONTAINED
UNDER ARTICLE TWO OF THE
INVESTIGATION WHICH IS THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
REALLY IT WAS DON MCGANN, THE
MEMBER OF THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
TALKING TO ANOTHER MEMBER WHEN
IT CAME TO THE MUELLER
QUESTIONING.
BUT IF CONGRESS WERE TO SUBPOENA
HIM, THEN THAT IS ARTICLE 1 OF
THE CONSTITUTION AGAINST ARTICLE
THE CONSTITUTION AGAINST ARTICL2
THE CONSTITUTION AGAINST ARTICLO
THE CONSTITUTION AGAINST ARTICLF
THE CONSTITUTION AGAINST ARTICLT
THE CONSTITUTION AGAINST ARTICLE
THE CONSTITUTION AGAINST ARTICLC
THE CONSTITUTION AGAINST ARTICLN
THE CONSTITUTION AGAINST ARTICLT
THE CONSTITUTION AGAINST ARTICLO
THE CONSTITUTION AGAINST ARTICL.
I ASSUME THAT THE
PRESIDENT UNDER THAT PREMISE
WOULD BE ABLE TO EXERT EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
IT WOULD BE SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT.
TO THE POINT IS THAT THEY DID
NOT EXERT EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
OVER THE RELEASE OF THE MUELLER
REPORT.
BECAUSE THEY DID NOT DO THAT,
MAYBE YOU ARE IN A PROBLEM TO
PUT THE TWO FACE BACK INTO THE
TUBE IN TERMS OF WHETHER THEY
DID NOT EXERT EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE FOR DON MCGANN TALKING